[Music]
probably the most famous product of the
Enlightenment was the American
Declaration of Independence and
Constitution a blueprint for a form of
governance that tried to get the
benefits of of government
seeing as how Anarchy is worse because
you get spirals of vendetta and feuding
and violence you don't get the
coordination of large scale economies
without some kind of governance how do
you get the benefits of governance
without the perennial hazard that any
one given a bit of power will aggrandize
their power and and become my despotic
so the checks and balances of American
democracy were a way of I think of it as
negotiating a middle route between the
the violence of Anarchy and Anarchy does
lead to violence the we were not never
noble savages that lived in harmony
regions of the world without government
are almost invariably violent but also
avoiding the violence of tyranny namely
you give someone power they're going to
use it to maximize their benefits their
power their longevity if their reign at
the expense of people democracy is a way
of getting of steering between these
extremes of having a government that
that exerts just enough violence to
prevent people from preying on each
other without preying on the people
itself now in practice it's no one has
ever developed a democracy that works
particularly well if judged in absolute
terms democracies are always messy
they're always unequal they always
involve lobbying and power grabs but all
the alternative so far have been worse
democracies seldom go to war with each
other they have higher standards of
living they have higher levels of
happiness they have higher levels of
health and they're the obvious preferred
destinations for people who vote with
their feet the whole world wants to live
in a democracy it's an ongoing project
it's
currently under threat from a number of
directions but there's never been a time
in which we've had a well-functioning
democracy in terms of meeting all the
criteria in a high school civics class
[Music]